just going everyone Clinton Jones here
just wanted to go over how my previous
video was made the ugliest man in the
world which is apparently me so one
thing a lot of people don't know about
me is I actually looked this ugly in
real life and all in all my other videos
I just motion attract you know a normal
face onto myself that looked like this
so the real work is done here not here
so let's get started let's hide all of
our layers besides the raw footage and
you see that I have two tracker points
here and when I was filming this I
stayed as still as possible because I
knew it was gonna be really hard this
was actually one of the hardest one of
the hardest effects I've done in a long
long time so basically what I did was
when I would pull my lip down and when I
would want it to like freeze what I
would do is just when it got to the
frame right about I guess here I would
take a screenshot of this by going
composition save frame as file and I
would save that picture out and in
Photoshop I would mask out my fingertips
here and then just use the clone tool
and get parts of the lip up here and
just paint it in down here I also use
the burn and dodge tool to you know make
it blend better so once I got that
picture I brought it back into After
Effects and I masked it out and I
feathered it so that I just and then I
just motion tracked that picture over my
face so in the in the raw footage
obviously it doesn't stick you know it
looks like this but if you turn on the
mouth in the mouth shadow it's stuck
like this so that's kind of how I did
that so everything that that sticks are
just basically pictures motion tracked
on to my face same with the ears you
know I pull the ears out to here and
when I let go they obviously come back
but I motion track the picture here
of when I pulled them out same with
everything else that's what I did for
everything now notice that my ears since
there are a picture and they're
feathered out you know they're in front
of my hands so I had to make a new layer
make a mask and I had to go frame by
frame and this took so long oh my gosh
it just oh god it was terrible but I
mean it turned out pretty well so I had
to mask everything frame by frame I mean
it seems it doesn't seem as hard as it
looks but it's not even hard it's just
really annoying
oh so once I got that you know I smacked
myself and kind of like funky here kind
of like a weird like avatar thing with
the ears but like that's when you know
you just turn off the layers right here
so the next frame everything's gone
when your motion tracking and parenting
stuff to the objects the null objects
you want to add motion blur on them to
make it look realistic look at all the
tracks I have here these are all just
separate tracks because I didn't just
use these tracking points I used like my
pupils here I used my that year the
bottom of my ear here my nostrils just
you know whatever I can get the best
track from so that was basically how I
did it and then I had to let's see here
all of these are masks to take out these
tracking points so if I were to turn all
these on hopefully those will go away
yeah and you can kind of tell like you
can kind of tell that it's like you know
it's not too it's not perfect but when
you know if you didn't if no one told
you you wouldn't really know so if I
turn it back on you can see my skin is
kind of a lighter around those points
because I am color blind by the way so
it's it's kind of hard for me so you
know I do what I got to do anyway umm
what else what else these are yeah I've
been over these tracks all the tracks
here
I had yeah just you know some masks one
thing was like people said that I messed
up right when I like when I did this
thing here which is disgusting as I went
over where my hands went behind the lips
now I tried it with them going over the
lips and it didn't look that great and
just look better this way so I left it
like this but um that's pretty much it
you know some people posted in the
comments like you know you can do
effects and everything but if you don't
have like a good creative way of doing
it then I mean it's just like who cares
so when you guys are doing your effects
try and think of like a really creative
way of doing it like Freddy did the the
whole rocking out on the car thing where
he like climbed out of his car on the
freeway and played guitar on the roof
it's a really cool video it's like you
just need to come with creative ways of
doing effects and you can really get
some cool stuff but yeah that's kind of
how that effect worked and expect more
stuff in the future and also thank you
to all my new subscribers I know I got a
lot from Freddy so yes expect some more
stuff thank you